how did you learn story structure
i learned it in uh initially learned it
at nyu
i had a um a screenwriting profession
professor by the name of stephen siegel
[Music]
who really
you know he was a he was tough
but fair and he was a stickler for
um not just story structure
but format and
to this day i still have his voice in my
head a little bit
when i'm writing i became maybe at times
too wedded to certain formatting
but he really taught me the bare bones
of
how to write a script um i think
you know when i was young again it was
that urge just to get to the just to
start writing
not to really think about the story and
plot it out
i think it became much clearer to me
about how to
you know again story structure you know
character development
as i as i got older and and got out of
film school but he definitely planted
the seeds that i then sort of sewed
later on as i
again evolved as a writer
when you left film school did you i know
you said that you realized at some point
that new york was probably
not for you at the time right did you
think that you would get a job working
in a production company what was in your
mind
that you as a career yeah um i mean for
me it was to just be in the business and
see where
you know the day you know to see where i
could go
i was pretty fortunate because when i
came out here
i had a lot of interviews right away i
had so my first job out of nyu had been
at um writers and artists which is
was purchased by paradigm probably maybe
even 20 years at this point
but they were still like they had a new
york in an la office
and they had a a nice stable of like
james gandolfini at the time was rep by
them
they had some other fairly name actors
and the new york the new york agents rep
like they
i think they actually had may have had
um
[Music]
half the cast on um sopranos so they
wrecked a lot of
you know broadway and film and tv actors
so that was my first job out of school
when i moved to la i initially was
interviewing at management companies and
other agencies
i knew i didn't want to be an agent but
i thought just getting the
experience and learning the business was
most important
i worked at icm for
about a second it was literally a second
it was probably three days
i worked for a very big talent agent
there and quickly realized that
i was just not going to cut it so
my roommate at the time
i was i remember walking out icm and
just
breathing a sigh of relief because
i had i feel like a monkey had been off
my back so i'm like okay i know
there's no way i'm going to work in the
agency business
at all or matt as a manager you know
that i just can't do it i'm not
cut from that cloth there's a certain
type
and i am not he or she
so my roommate at the time
for whatever reason he had been sent a
job opportunity as a writer's pa
on this fox show
at the time and i went in and i
interviewed i got the job
and then the first day my first day
there the show was canceled
oh no so it lasted a couple more weeks
and
it was they the same production company
was producing this comedy
and it was a sitcom that they are they
were developing
uh it was an ed burns pilot and um
i remember because it was the same
company they were
saving on supplies so we brought the
supplies from i was at sony at the time
i moved the supplies to
um uh the cbs radford
and i walked in i said hey you guys are
starting do you need a
a pa a writer's pa they're like actually
we need a pa and i was like
great here's my resume and i got the job
and i worked for about a month and i was
a night pa
and i have to say like i've worked some
very interesting jobs but
driving in la at night was
just this it was a it was a
um i i don't want to use the word
mystical but it was
it was definitely an interesting
experience you know
because at that time this was just i
mean people had email but
a lot of executives and other writers
wanted the actual script delivered
so i was going from pasadena to
you know as far out as i may have gone
to malibu and this was like i think i
worked like 27 hours straight
but it was but it was wild it was fun
like i i
learned the lay of the land doing that
at night it was
i was kind of on my own i was you know
you know driving probably 80 90 miles an
hour in my
little uh chevy cavalier all around the
town
but it was an experience and it was
really it was a lot of fun
and i learned a lot and anyway
long story short that pilot was uh being
shot and i had a friend who was working
at law and order at the time
and he said you know there's a writers a
writer's production assistant job open
on
this new law and order show there it was
criminal intent
and they said do you are you interested
in
i'm like yes i would love to because i
think this this pilot is ending and i
you know they're shooting the pilot it
hadn't been picked up at that point i
was like
yes if it's permanent i love it and i
wound up getting that job
and i was a law in art on the law worked
on the law and order shows for close to
two years
so you know i i had that background in
television and then
you know from there um i got into uh
to research and i worked and working at
fox for many years as a research analyst
um while i was still writing and it was
my day job but i always was able to find
jobs that supported my writing and and i
was able to
you know one fed the other and um
yeah it was it was definitely uh back to
your question about
you know the business and and getting
into it um
[Music]
you know it was it was definitely i i
always knew i wanted to write and
the but keeping an open mind on the day
job type
led me to in a lot of different
directions and you know i had a time
where i did temp and
attempt in marketing attempt in
post-production i worked in
post-production i
i had an array of different jobs and you
know
while i was still writing and you know
always always putting in the time and
and that's now is
has definitely paid off but um you know
anyone who's coming out and trying to
get in the film business
i would say you know sign up with the
temp agency
you know work in an agency or management
company you may like it maybe writing's
not for you and you may
decide you are cut from that cloth to be
an agent uh but it's a
you know i think it's just a matter of
keeping as open mind as possible in
learning all different aspects of the
business while you're continuing to hone
your craft
did the driving job the driving pa job
did that inspire any stories
for scripts no no it was it was just
um you know again i was pretty new to la
so i was still
like you know again just i think i was
just focused on learning the terrain at
the time
um and i do remember i was working on a
script that i
again earlier in my career one of the
mistakes i made was
you know working working scripts over
and over and over again until it's like
look enough you've written this you know
written
20 different drafts it's all coming out
the same you know
maybe just need to put this in the
drawer and step away
and start go for something else you know
beating your head against the wall isn't
i i don't obviously is not productive
and i know that um you know if you have
a really great idea and you love it and
you're
you're you're really wedded to it um
that's great but sometimes the best
thing you can do for a script that
you're wedded to and you really want to
tell but it's not working is just
to take a step back and you know put it
away and start and
work on something else um you know i i
know
again early in my career i should have
done that with a few scripts where i'm
like i'm just focusing i'm
i'm beating my head against the wall and
and that was that was about working
harder not smarter at the time
and in hindsight those scripts the best
thing those things
those scripts could have used was was
better structure better
um uh better plotting
and more and a better outline and i
hadn't really fully evolved to that
place where i was able to really put
you know to to to write an effective
outline and and really explore the story
that way i think i was just so quick to
go right to jump right into the
screenplay and
you know it leaves yourself open to a
lot of problems
you